45 seconds of logos again awesome
Disney bidc as well this is Superman
even though this movie is great like a
solid a that doesn't change the fact
that it's the third best Toy Story feel
super short fluff sequel finds time for
over three goddamn minutes of imaginary
Buzz Lightyear video game adventure Bowl
seriously buzz breathe like a discount
Darth Vader and he's white - I know Gary
Rhinestone was a big part of the sound
of this movie but damn dude how many
times you're gonna go to that Star Wars
well it doesn't be the first year I'm
this cowboy camp all because am i stupid
what does in it has anyone checked with
the king prankster jerk boy who wrote
that would take you to camp with or
without your hat does he have any reason
to think he can't go to camp without the
Hat cuz if not what he needs a
psychiatrist more than he needs and II
figure would you find it well that's the
bad news
so we did slink steal the Hat back from
the dog and then managed outrun said dog
because you know slink is a slinky with
very poor motor skills right okay see
the humans in this house continue to
give the toys extremely helpful warnings
before anyone walks into a room and has
their world changed forever
five minutes hmm they would take 15
minutes bare minimum to set up all these
army men that's probably the joke
they're making but five minutes is five
minutes
somehow this hasn't happened before now
also a small terror will somehow mean
and II can't take this toy he's been
taking the cowboy camp for years to
cowboy camp Candyland mousetrap twister
guess who life
where's the fucking chutes and ladders
assholes Andy's mom has had some work
done no she looks nothing like she did
in the last movie is what I'm saying you
know I feel like Andy continued his love
of woody simply because the first movie
demanded a happy ending this kid would
have moved on from woody two weeks after
they moved into the new house if that
would he drops his dead arm but then
also has a perfect view of Andy getting
into the guy Super Nintendo
let's play some Bomberman right fucking
now you know if you're gonna make a joke
about cousin AJ Joe JimBob writing a
book about the real real big trucks you
might want to make that thing 300 pages
later you know what I mean burn nearly
every board game in the stack is also a
movie with the same name guess who movie
really went off the rails when it came
to adapting the source material I send a
whole bunch of stuff and the whole thing
turned out to be a dream sequence but
the movie is a dickhead for spending its
first 12 minutes on video game footage
and dream sequences also even toys have
disturbing dreams
now what if this happen while Andy was
in the room nah she just told him that
to calm him down and then put me on the
shelf yeah but you guys are living tall
he's right why have you never made your
presence known since you were put on the
shelf does the shelf have some sort of
magical properties we aren't aware of no
one could hear me
yeah your squeaker is broken but not
your voice yard sale all the toys
freaked out about a yard sale sign the
mom is hammering into the front lawn but
I'm much more concerned about a mother
who opens a yard sale on her property
without even so much as a hint about
which toys our son is willing to part
with and while I'm at it how convenient
is it that Andy's not home right now
okay point to the yard sale dog
understands English or you already
taught at the command 4 to the yard sale
I mean I can suspend my disbelief with
the best of them but you're stretching
it here man
these toys move in the presence of
humans so damn often it's a wonder they
ever even try to pretend they're
non-animated toys back Andy sleep after
all that trouble hiding woody will now
ride the back of a dog in full view of
anyone who cares to look up super
well-trained toy friendly dog is utterly
clueless when his best toy friend falls
off in the front yard because the script
call for conflict perhaps the least
believable thing about any of the Toy
Story movies is that al from Al's Toy
Barn would be lurking at this exactly
artists exact temporary moment when
would he finds himself trapped and what
he falling on the table would
accidentally trigger his voice prompt
which is the only reason al even found
out he was here I mean god damn he's
stealing woody Wow who is a known local
celebrity featured in tons of
commercials thinks he can steal woody no
problem right after being a pushy
bastard about buying it and don't give
me that he dresses like a chicken stuff
either because his face is clearly
visible buzz his hands somehow punches
this trunk open which I'd normally sit
but I'm gonna take this in back for all
the detail the animators put in to show
scratches all around it's keyhole a nice
touch indeed you didn't have a beard
like that did you guys see this dude or
not how does a ZZ Top beard ever become
part of the equation
picky picky bitch just slink would be
amazing at cinemasins but ham would be
amazing at being our critics I can't
believe I have to drive
this asshole dresses in his chicken
costume before driving to the commercial
shoot if al comes bursting back into the
room right now these living toys are all
busted as hell there's no way they can
all get back into place in time not to
mention how many styrofoam peanuts
they've strewn around the room at this
point but toys play dead when humans are
around thing really loses its luster
when you just script the humans out of
the way whenever you need it do you get
the sense that Joan Cusack signed up for
this because she thought it was the
sequel to toys
oh wait nobody would do that stupid
question why the prodigal son has
returned
you know he's evil because the voice is
Sideshow Bob what the hell why does
collector al dude have priceless woody
magazines strewn across the floor answer
he doesn't just made a cool shot so they
did it every single one of these tapes
his episodes 4 through 6 they've been
sitting here dumbfounded watching TV for
hours and even if al somehow ended up
doing a hundred takes on his chicken
soup commercial across the street
there's no way these rich knew that was
happening so they should be caught dead
to rights as living toys by all measure
of logic and sanity they are at the very
least some of the stupidest toys to ever
forget to pretend not to be alive and
now you'll learn the movie set this
whole record player thing up just for a
cheap record scratch gag at the sound of
something shocking yes go and somehow
clean up all those styrofoam peanuts on
the floor and put away the videotapes
and turn off the TV and Jesus this is
hopeless isn't it we have a friend in
need unnecessary patriotism and that
foods are broadcast day one TV channels
haven't been signing off this way since
decades before this fucking movie takes
place but whatever makes the parental
nostalgia Bell go ring-a-ding-ding right
I see that cheese all over his fingers
but how'd it get there
this bowl is completely full he fell
asleep before he had time to eat any of
it I'm blind is woody to have not seen
any of this prior to stepping on the
first cheese puffs
just like in real life horses are so
worried about being helpful they don't
realize how much noise they make wait
well lucky bulls I decided to wake up
and join what he done because I don't
think he could've climb the couch
without it let's just say L wakes up now
by chance is there some kind of toy port
where woody would face charges of
failing to pretend to not be alive
bullseye ignores hundreds of actual
cheese bumps in order to lick the dust
off the fingers of a dude I'm pretty
sure didn't even eat any himself yep
Tony's can smell who knew somehow a
Pixar thought this would be hilarious
dialogue for it suddenly awoke and
creepy guy to say no idea where they
were going with that
but it's creepy as hell super serious
toy collector dude pays no heed to his
cheesy fingers while picking up a
priceless toy woody accuses Jesse of
turning on the TV when he tried to take
back his own but somehow she didn't see
sneaky pete do it why are there spikes
on this road when there's no boom
barrier blocking it massive miracle also
apparently no one notices these cones
moving by themselves Road that was
pretty much abandoned a minute ago we'll
decide to be the hardest level of
Frogger ever so the heroes have a
challenge also I'm pretty sure these
toys caused a 14 car accident where many
many people were killed we just didn't
see it because the movie is rated G this
pipe fell off a truck that had to haul
all sorts of momentum to stop and yet it
rolls like a gang of nerdy guys are
pushing it uphill toy fixer dude turns
out to be the old man from the Pixar
chest short which I suppose thrills and
delights me to no end right here can't
rush art you hear that marvel why is the
automatic door open and working but the
closed sign is still in the window
someone didn't do their job all the way
these toys all just saw a human worker
come in here but now they're spreading
out just openly wandering around
shouting woody as though no humans could
be nearby while I admit it would be
weird to see an aisle full of other use
buzz already experienced the whole I'm
not unique and I'm a toy thing last
movie overstock this raises an
interesting philosophical question
though at what point the toys in this
universe become self-aware so you can't
defeat Zurg that's what it is
wait until you to the era of DLC and
in-game purchases t-rex you've got it
good right now trust me this thing has
working gas and brake pedals get the
piccata game Roby these guys are in a
car driving around a toy store where
there are no helpful warnings from
Andy's mom that someone's about to come
into the room nobody thinks that if it
swaps in a second buzz in place of woody
then I'll overlook the fact that it's
literally repeating an entire scene from
the first movie
know how the rest of this goes at this
point right movie is wrong these Barbies
know how to party one question though
why didn't they let any of the Ken dolls
join the bash they'd be in the same
aisle right
also no other toy sold in the store is
stupid enough to be a week at this point
but all the Barbie stuff is having a
pool party right now
what do toys do in the age of security
cameras by the way I feel sad for this
Barbie because she is cooking a steak
that will never get cooked enough short
sighted retailers did not order enough
dolls to meet demand Disney complaining
about not getting enough money also oh I
guess they've more than made up for it
by over buying on the next go around see
how that works
Tiny Tim can still get his operation
after all know if this guy was the true
collector he's been made out to be he'd
know better than to put his greasy
fingers all over the priceless toy just
to take an obscene number of posed
photos in order to then sell said price
Latoya oils dust potential damage this
guy is ignoring all the obsessive
collector basics it's like printing my
own money what serious toy collector or
serious eBay seller would take and use
Polaroids of the merchandise sure it
looks better for the shot to have him
holding physical pics but it's dumb as
hell he's going to fax them to the buyer
take too many pictures use Polaroid
instant film and then fax results this
guy has never sold a high-value item in
his life damn this scene is going to
appeal to my soft side and make me
remove sins isn't it every one of these
transitions suggests this girl outgrew
her love of horses for stuff like makeup
and music what's going to outgrow her
love of being a stereotype huh
this suggests that Emily grew up during
the 60s and 70s what with the record
player and the posters but she has a
poster for a concert at Pixar studio for
the lemurs on November 25th 1999 the day
after the release of this movie
something's fishy about that I don't
know what and this donation center is
out in the middle of nowhere buzz just
managed to escape at the perfect time
and sees Rex's tail hanging out of this
bag so he knows where to go next
buzz somehow knew these particular toys
and this order would lead to him flying
toward the door sir dory just happened
to be mixed in with the bargain bin I
guess because no one likes to buy the
buzz let your villain but no one wants
to buy Buzz Lightyear either according
to the shelves in this place
imposter buzz is able to pull this vent
out you know I think that buzz
went to his head these idiots still
haven't figured out they've got the
wrong bus
elevator X not gonna actually buzz then
decides not to use the elevator but then
yeah elevator X marketing no that looks
like a thing I can't see since my eyes
are covered wait a minute are you saying
mr. potato
I works even when it's not attached to
him this guy was blind in the last movie
when they knocked out his eyes so you're
filthy cheaters Pixar you're a child's
plaything you are a toy symmetry retro
version of Randy Newman's song from the
first movie gives woody the idea he
needs to advance the plot I thought the
guy did a really professional job fixing
woody but apparently he can just scrape
the paint off with a couple of swipes
right no one heard or saw him exit the
box and walk over here and do this
totally also stinky Pete tightens the
screws on this vent the only method Andy
Hepler escaped but didn't do this any
time when he knew everyone was asleep
buzz and gang react desert before Zerg
is even visible sir took his sweet-ass
time finding buzz Denis although maybe
he had complications involving gated to
this floor but I'm still sending it
because of this perfect timing
this should mean mr. Potato Head lost
all his body parts to the elevator shaft
but it doesn't you killed my father I
already know also this line of toys is a
serious ripoff of Star Wars from the
story to their sound effects I know this
is just another Neumann Dennis Nedry
character wing Knight is playing here
and he's evil and dumb but can he
seriously not hear the sleepy behind him
Rex thinks pushing the toys ERG off an
elevator is the same as defeating him in
the video game and is a guy who actually
killed a number of mother brains in real
life I can tell you that my inability to
beat them in video games left my
frustration intact mr. Potato hat
somehow stomps these heavy double doors
from closing which is supposed Pizza
anyone pizza truck from the first movie
ex not gonna change it from the outside
I didn't realize until rewatching this
how much lip service this movie pays to
the first one I guess I should be glad
that these toys are somehow finding a
way to drive this car but this really
goes against all the rules and general
stuff they needed to worry about in the
first movie and plus it's toys driving a
car somehow coordination between all
these idiot toys on their first time
driving makes me kind of Angry Drive
Angry
there he is how did al perk his car and
get to check-in so fast how our buzzes
feet protruding through this pet
carriers floor in order to propel it
along the carpet this works it's not a
Pixar movie unless there's a giant
factory or maze of conveyer belts to
navigate Pixar goes for that classic
boot joke which is something beavis and
butt-head do America did two years
earlier and everyone did whenever Butte
Montana was found it it's amazing what
transpires to make what do you look
exactly the same when he finally gets
into the arms of Andy Toy Story 2 steals
the flashing camera weapon from rear
window and that itchy and scratchy land
episode of The Simpsons toy Horus with
no real moves will catch up to this
gas-powered vehicle American Airlines
huh dori horse was running at the same
speed as it about to take off jumbo jet
I'm not even mad that's amazing these
toys put great faith in the fact that
Andy's mom won't find it weird when Andy
mentions this tour oh wow new toys yeah
we're seeing a girlie doll what's not to
love when you like exclusively dude
Deutsch and only use Bo Peep when you
need a female for woody to save it's
good that al approved an ad where he was
so sad we could see the result that this
comeuppance mr. Schad looked in the toy
box and found me an extra squeaker which
means there's another toy with its
squeaker completely ripped out fine of
that or this toy comes with a spare
squeaker of some sort which I'm not
buying for one minute when did all these
Barbies make it into the household and
his little sister's like two years old
she's not playing with multiple Barbies
yet is she whoa I don't remember eating
that now let's think about this for a
second this is an animated movie about
toys coming to life when humans aren't
around
but these outtakes tell us they're
actually actors pretending to be toys
that only come to life when the humans
on the run Oh behind-the-scenes toys are
filming this no it's humans filming
living toy actors alright I think my
existentialism just threw me a left
uppercut isn't this exciting Heimlich
Pixar accidentally puts ants in Toy
Story 2 dreamworks is gonna be pissed
when they find out
now we're gonna take some pictures I'm
gonna have another sip of wine I'm going
to take some more pictures
space the final frontier
mirror football practice
oh no this you gotta give me the time I
did a test run on this thing that took
me 20 minutes maybe pushed a team and
you gotta give us community much but
Simpson the spirited little scamp who
twice foiled my evil schemes and sent me
to this dank urine-soaked until my name
is Darth Vader I am an extraterrestrial
from the planet Vulcan don't tell me
which so much for stopping and which
zone is for moaning I think I'm getting
the black lung Bob it's Christmas time
so what are you gonna do when you're
tired of watching the usual holiday
movie reruns besides watch cinema since
of course I'll be watching some
wholesome anime on crunchyroll
crunchyroll is an anime streaming
service that offers the largest most
diverse collection of anime series that
you can watch an HD with no ads will get
you new shows as soon as one actually
here in Japan what's it take to say
that's faster than you could pirate
those who didn't believe I can do it go
get me the best part you can enjoy it
all free for 30 days when you go to
crunchyroll.com slash cinemasins
yes that's a month of unlimited
professionally subtitled anime manga and
drama titles that you can enjoy on all
your devices all you have to do is click
the link of the description or head to
crunchyroll.com slash cinemasins to get
started